hey guys Mary here with Jacob Lichty and
we are going to be playing Astro near
which I actually played at e3 this last
year didn't I but there's been some
changes most notably in something we
didn't do last time that I'm so excited
to do this time is we're gonna be
playing together on this planet yes I'm
just waiting here on the planet and
waiting for her to drop down is that you
in the upper left hand corner waving to
me and this little little sign and
that's me about to docks I'm actually
gonna launch this little dude
oh man I'm pretty excited now in our
previous playthrough if you guys didn't
see it that's fine we're gonna kind of
start off nice and easy here I'm so
excited about this game this is a space
exploration kind of survival game but
it's really heavily weighing on
creativity and multiplayer and that's
why I'm so excited to be able to play
with you on this adventure not just
because you know this way better than me
and you'll probably make sure I survive
but also these types of games
exploration games are just so much more
fun with friends and like that's
something that's missing from basically
any giant exploration procedural
generated game now is that you can't
play with anyone there you are yeah we
love the co-op aspect of a game it's fun
to go around collecting resources
actually I'm gonna help you out this
whole session always collect resources
for you and kind of let you play yeah I
want the audience to kind of get a nice
overview not just of you what you're
gonna do in this game but how to survive
because this is very survival based
you'll see right now I have a battery
pack on the back of my little pack and
there's yellow that's the battery
there's also blue that is my oxygen
which I need and now I'm gonna get out
this little tool here this is pretty rad
and we're collecting compounds right now
yes the compounds are the basic resource
that you can use to build a lot of the
early game items even give you some
diamonds you can give me oh I'm out of
power already that's crazy let's run
back to base and get more it looks like
the sun's going down so I'll show the
users a little bit more about this where
should I be extending this just click
down
it doesn't matter okay so this is my
little residence center and I can open
up my backpack here I've been collecting
resin so I'll put a resin in there oh no
I didn't even get the right one so I can
make stuff with this at least so it
didn't completely waste my time maybe
I'll get a solar power that's pretty
helpful yeah well you're showing some of
that stuff I can go Thanks he he's
become inadvertently my workhorse which
I really appreciate
so a solar power is pretty good what
else do you think I should be getting a
battery
that'll tank is good that sounds really
nice
I run out of that pretty quickly and now
something I I learned I have these
little extra pieces on the side that I
can put things but a lot of these pieces
they take my inventory space so it's
kind of a guess it's like a trade-off
situation so maybe have eight slots in
your backpack and you can kind of choose
depending on the situation that's so
nice of you taken all right cool so now
we can extend this more if we want to
yes if you grab those two input also put
those on as well oh yeah make make a
bigger base here all right let's do it
just run around collecting resources for
me this is like this is the very oh [ __ ]
so here we go now we have a full-on
builder here and we can we can make
various things but we need for compound
to make a lot of this stuff vehicle Bay
that sounds good
and now I'm able to go so much farther
here I have one compound I'll put it in
there oh this is so nice I can't believe
you were able to do that so quickly but
I do want to show I kind of want to
follow you next time into the into the
wild blue yonder yeah I'm actually
before we did that I'll grab a compound
and we can build some tethers that'll
help us develop that sounds nice yeah
what do you think I should print first
printer research vehicle Bay you read my
mind and here it is like this is the
future this is this is us building our
future on Mars here
yes service simplified base building
experience like it's not it's not has to
doesn't have all the scientific stuff
that you'd have on a real Mars mission
but but we like we like to hint that
what real humans are actually doing in
the solar system I mean it makes a lot
of sense right like this is these are
like the basic building blocks of having
a functional society it's stuff like
being able to travel how far can you go
before your battery pack dies I mean yes
actually what I'm going to end it build
a generator here too because it's
nighttime so the solar panels won't
allow us to charge up to that vehicle
Bay but a generator works at all times
I'm gonna run over here a little bit and
collect a resin yeah so I've got some
organic that I've collected from these
plants now I learned last time see how I
only have these eight precious precious
spots but what if I like fill up of
resin but I need compound or something
else I can just put them on the ground
and deal with them later and you said
they they won't they shouldn't really go
away too quickly I kind of just like
hang out there like a little building
blocks it's pretty nice yeah if you look
over there I've got the the generator
going what are you charging if it's made
a generator yeah oh there it is I'm
looking you see the battery charging up
yeah this seems like the kind of thing
like of course I could play this for fun
and just enjoy myself but it also seems
slightly like just an educational tool
to understand how to even do this at all
and like what projects to build and and
battery oh my god my car but this is the
fun part okay
Rover shuttle yeah kind of teachers
teachers players like resource
management having to choose what their
equipment is for this situation oh so I
have to we have to fill this with
compounds I've got a bunch more here as
well how do you keep getting them so
quickly I mean it's almost like I work
on the gamers
crazy I want to come with you I'm
following you this time this way all
right let's go it is nighttime and now
it's something that is a bit dark in
this game as you can totally croak and
it's happened you can die in this game
you need to monitor your life you can
fall in a hole and die but you you
actually you don't take like fall damage
or anything oh my god it's so cruel yes
on the other plane this there's a lot
more steep cliffs and stuff that you
kind of have to work around what else
can kill you there's there's plant life
yes point life and hazards I think
that's really rad I am I'm a my very
first I mean earlier playthrough of
course I was trying to just investigate
and I got I got killed by a mushroom or
something it was an exploding piece of
fungus that if you deform under it
without being careful you can I like
poisoned myself to death actually this
this rover has enough for compound here
so I'll just kick it off I didn't even
make enough compound for one of me and I
couldn't do anything we can share
resources like pretty easily I can put
them in your pack and we can survive
that way so that's pretty neat like how
much we can achieve together I mean I
feel like we're just get going so much
farther now I never did build those
tethers that I had let me let me do that
real quick
wait what are you getting now so I was
just harvesting some of those I this is
a grass to get something organic no this
grass yeah and if you have the generator
then you can put those on the generator
to use and you say you could build
storage that we're not just completely
wasting time looks like there's man-made
stuff here it's pretty interesting like
this yes if you dig it up you might be
able to find some rarer items in there
really
I'm doesn't tethers to let us go a
little further I'm investigating
wreckage
I need way more power place tether Oh
actually let me hand you these two
others first and you'll be able to
actually show that off there you go
do I have to put my gun away right great
so now I just place it I just put those
in your backpack okay on it done and
then now you can hit too you can use
those where do you want it if you put it
close to the base you can kind of build
them out outwards from the base how far
do I know I can go when I hit T yeah
yeah there you go that's my max yeah
freaking out it's freaking out yeah so
we're we're still finishing up again
we've got about my laps maybe month and
a half until we release in December
that's true so this game is not out but
it is very much playable and what I love
about what you guys have done with your
with your building so far is you guys
have been super transparent about what
this is capable of doing and what it's
going to be and what your expectations
are for the game yeah what's what's most
important to us is that we kind of build
a foundation that we can build off of in
the long run because we have access game
and what we would love more than
anything is just to get a large
community started from the get-go right
so they can be involved in what they
want like what do they want to do with
this game or what are people interested
in like what's the funnest part about
this game is it like you know for me
like I enjoy digging up these secrets
and like finding out what's been here
long ago I find this stuff really
fascinating but not everybody some
people might be more interested in the
survival aspects or maybe people want
animals or something else often what if
I dig myself a hole and I can't get out
do you have to come save me
okay yeah maybe if you like we're out of
power and you can't dig yours oh you
like bring you a battery or this you was
it there's tethers all the way over here
yeah yeah there you go you're just over
there doing doing really magical things
yes and that's actually what's great is
if there's somebody who's played a lot
before and they want to like bring
somebody else in
experience they can just happen join
their game and it'll be I serve a more
handful the experience there's secrets
in there actually one of these is a
research is the research item and I will
actually give us how do we get in there
research trade platform it's not
something new that we can build because
we found ok the blueprint for easy get
in oh we have a seat here this is
actually perfect because we were gonna
have to build a seat over there but I
just found one in the spaceship if you
just got in there how's that into the
spaceship look over here I've got I'm
just carrying this guy to the base
that's super worth it yes actually
investigating yeah dead ships totally
worked out yes if you walk up to that
and hit a hit tab you can you get in
there oh we can drive around there there
you go how do we oh my god bus look at
my little seat
something really quickly yes it's gonna
sped up a bit just but that's great you
know like nobody wants to sit there you
know picking mushrooms for four hours
like I have a vehicle in what is this
ten minutes this has been great yeah I
think like first time players will spend
a lot of time just learning the game
blowing Heitzig having fun you can golf
as many changes as why yeah I mean you
could just spend the first half hour
just building lots of tethers and going
straight down into caves and just do
whatever you want so this is now being
charged now let me ask you this this is
Riley something that happens right you
like go on these crazy adventures and
then you kind of like kind of get
yourself killed by like going somewhere
you can't come back from probably happen
need to keep oxygen aware at all times
and so a big part of the game is
figuring out how to give yourself power
and oxygen even when you're far away
from your face it's actually what are
you doing now I'm just getting more
compound compound is the for the major
resource things that everybody wants
yeah I don't know if we'll get around to
this Fourier but I think eventually we
want to have the ability to create
automated systems to to get lots of
resources all at once and so if you kind
of build up to it you can just have
these machines that are just constantly
harvesting some of these resources for
you it's kind of levelling up from the
early game experience what have you
found that people want from you a lot of
people just want to be able to do to be
creative with with what they're making
and with what they're building and just
and how they play the game as though do
you have the ability to I'm like yeah
like how are you going to be impacting
the game based on like what people want
like what about people who want to be
able to make things look the way they
want it to look like have a more of a
creative say yeah we definitely want
like customized suits and backpacks and
and even like bass elements that we
might we might even in the far future
have the ability to have like sets of
of machines and spaceships and and
modules and stuff that kind of like go
with a particular space company and say
you know we it's like if you if you want
the one the one that harkens like SpaceX
for example you could get this pack that
without copyright infringement
just like rhyme the name or something
but yeah people after they have their
own tech company their own space company
and they when it's like fuel are you
building a second Rover I think what
what a next thing I want to build for
you was a business spaceship oh yeah
that makes sense where shall we go
no wait can we go together oh we can I
think that's one of the bugs right now
is that I can't join you in this
spacecraft you're building a spaceship
for me to leave you on this planet to
die I mean I'll be fine it's pretty dark
actually are probably more dangerous for
you because you'll need to bring some
stuff with you what kind of stuff
compound yeah just building a shit-ton a
compound for myself I am getting in my
rover again I say we need some fuel for
this thing yeah how do I make sure the
battery is charging or is it it's just
really slow so I see you cuz it was
tethered but it looks like it's not
actually one thing we can do we can
stick this generator put on the back
here uh-huh
and then given you organic do I have I
have resin I don't think I got any of
the stuff that you actually needed
there's no organic in this how do you
know which stuff you need I mean it
clearly says it but like is there like a
visual way to like easily see what you
need yeah
oftentimes it'll have the text of what
you need on the item there but I need to
clean up some of that that's one of my
tasks before Thea before we ship is to
kind of make some of that little cleaner
more obvious right another issue with
you know
running around taking all these items is
you just basically have a planet filled
with holes but something I noticed is
not only can I can I take away here but
I can also add I can um oh yeah I can
add alt key lets me build and I over I
can plan with
I can make up a little wall here nice
you could build them a monument of our
likeness so that people know that we
were here yeah if you spend a lot of
time you can build actually anything out
of this array and I think that's be
pretty neat week how do you find the
sculpting ability though of it do you
think people could make like some really
cool stuff they could I don't have the
patience to sit down there and make some
of the stuff but I mean some people will
make some really interesting stuff we
expect I have all this crap I don't need
mostly resin do I do with all that stuff
it's just sitting there yes I'm making
fuels got she's gonna be a little tricky
here I put it in the hole
this will be our resin hole I'm gonna
try this so we have we researched the
trade platform which will let us if we
can get to work it'll let us trade for
different resources one of them is
actually fuel do be more present I do
it's in the resin hole perfect that's
actually good because sometimes there's
sandstorms that come through and if you
put put them in a little hole in the
ground it'll make them less likely to
blow away nice okay so that's like the
only time when you would lose your
resonance from something like that yeah
and given you compound
I am resin rich compound for well I've
got compound we admit we make a good
pair it's fine all right I'll put this
resin back in the resin whole trade pot
until you're needed again
I assume so this is a trade platform
which we have not shown off before and
it's it's also not finished but it works
oh this is Settlers of Catan this is
where you this is the three to one port
this is yeah is this sheep to resin you
can do is if you hit the arrows you can
select which which item you want to
trade for okay so let's say I wanted
copper we haven't had any do you hide
your same that's actually the fuel
hydrazine for fuel which is what we need
and then we need to put when you just
wait you could put whatever I'll see one
on there and whatever how do you know
that it's balanced it will so I need to
also indicate that a little better with
some work but are you saying right now I
can abuse this severely so I think it's
four to one for for the common items get
in your hole there we go for resins will
be will equal one fuel alright so I will
come over here and I will extract as
much as I can
and while you're doing that I'm gonna
see if I can build actually actually
what we can do we can to take the seat
off of the rover and put it on the
spaceship
there's resin in the air over here here
oh okay
again you guys are kinda still working
on this piece we got lots of time though
yeah we're at the point where we've got
most of the features in and now it's
just a matter of just finishing it up
then and you'll be doing a lot of
additional work post release as well
yeah that's right yeah we'll just be
continually working on the game Oh
perfect
so it says yield 1 so that means if you
hit the launch button in the front there
this little guy right here this down
arrow doing stuff wait where's it going
it's gonna go trade for some fuel first
weird I mean wherever I can find it just
goes into the sky and retrieves my item
yeah I think I think eventually like we
could actually have it you send it to
individuals like on your friends lists
or whatever you can trade back and forth
that way if you're not playing
synchronously if you do all kind of
stuff like that now we're on a desert
right now but I'd like to be clear this
game is the utmost procedural generation
where you can you know go to different
areas and planets every time I've
spawned I've been on a different terrain
I've been in snow I've been in I've been
at a grassy field which is really cool I
think it's really neat you guys have
developed a pretty large oh that's what
killed me
those are murder plants there's a lot of
different areas that you can go and
investigate all sorts of different plant
life yeah and you would not believe our
artist Adam has been cranking away on
different biomes what's Square this
important does actually like some dense
organics that you can use maybe there's
a bug they can't pick these up okay well
I can pick them up I just there we go
I go parallel cubes dense organic ice
actually looks like our
our friendly trade ship is back yes so
I've got I think this is us a networking
bug where I see that it has these
resources but they don't actually have
[ __ ] I'm almost out of oxygen but we do
have this fuel that I brought back to
the tether so you have fuel now huh yeah
so you and if you want you can actually
jump in there and in here I don't have
enough don't I need like food or
something to take with me yeah well
things that would help I mean so
actually very good am I ready for this
what we can do we could build a storage
actually they'll take a little bit I
mean if you want you could just die yeah
[ __ ] it let's just send me the space yes
I hit that button which but this one
yeah well bye
yes I may be you you'll be you'll be
orbiting here and if you wanted to and
it's all done in real time like there's
no loading screens like all this stuff
is really happening and something that I
think really should be stated is just
how pretty everything is this is a
really good looking game it's what you
can do if you hit that button at the top
there yeah you'll go to floor system
view and you can rotate around with with
and you can see that all these planets
and their moons are all simulating right
now around that Sun so there's the Sun
oh it's beautiful so here here we are
or such tiny little beings it's a
profound statement that we intend to
make yeah you're like kind of just
running around helping build power but
I'm on a I mean like the universe here
exploring the whole world
yeah what's neat with multiplayer week
you can actually plan separate planets
at the same time and in the future when
we keep making updates we can have like
these little waypoints that you can send
each other resources back and forth and
we can do all the kinds of stuff having
a Zen moment here but you could land on
that moon if you wanted to you could
yeah how far can I go what's like
where's my limit here I mean like could
I continue to investigate more planets
can I can I go outside of this solar
system like I can see I can easily click
on these but where else can I go yeah I
need to make a so you can limit how far
you can go on a single thing a gas or a
fuel but currently so we're shipping EA
with just a single source system and
then maybe in the future we'll the habit
so you can travel to even adjacent stars
and maybe that'll even have something to
do with how you go visit your friends if
you want to join them up for something
you wanna see this eclipse that's really
neat that's beautiful I've never
actually seen that before which is it's
that's why it's great to have new people
play it because I was fine they're
always breaking it or killing themselves
falling into holes or finding something
beautiful within your world it's a shame
yeah yeah it's really neat looking and
you guys have created a pretty good art
style that I think lends itself to what
you've made which is creating things out
of nothing being able to break down
every piece but it's not like an I don't
know it's not just like in an artistic
interpretation you can see the breakdown
of compounds and ever
and now the universe itself made out of
like these little triangles and polygons
like all together it's it's really
really nice yeah there's an early
decision to keep everything super simple
looking so that we can just kind of keep
everything on the screen there's not a
lot of menus and like numbers it's just
like what you see is what you get I
could definitely look at that all day
but where should I go should I travel
somewhere should I come back to you I
think you just go to new planets just
you can see a new one okay you can go
that moon if you want we can go to that
Jason planet you think I'm going to the
moon all right
it is happening framerate issues but it
should make it
come on get there little guy gonna do it
get there little dye see a giant blue
orb oh geez that's weird
this is new now do I have enough fuel to
get home or a my own bubble planet
you'll be stuck here so if you hit one
of those bubbles sure I made it
alright Here I am on a new moon that
I've never seen before
and the Sun is setting and again it's
very very very pretty and this is a very
different terrain we got uh looks like
more plant life it's green it's less
more vegetation on here let me hit tab
and roam around now unfortunately I've
lost my Rover that's on your planet
how's things going on your end that's
pretty normal it's kind of lonely to be
honest oh I want to come back and I I
had such purpose like finding all those
resources and and working towards
something but now I'm just some people I
got really sad I feel like I spent all
this time trying to leave and like I'm
just all alone over here now like I
don't know this is what I wanted it's
actually that's kind of it's an
interesting that it's that kind of works
like that because it kind of gets equal
motivation to kind of rejoin up after
they've kind of had these dangerous
excursions and yeah the people that the
stories that kind of come out a
multiplayer play are always really
interesting I found another seat
I'm seat rich alright let's see where do
we want to go I want to make sure I
don't die here actually I'm doing okay I
got a lot of oxygen a lot of battery but
I'd like to go home I have a little bit
of fuel do you think I could survive a
trip home should be able to yeah the bye
moon I'll miss you
okay
saving game to space hopefully this
works
oh my god it makes me feel very small
that's so cool this one I'd really like
to come back home okay cuz this is my
home yeah coming home
let's let's see where you land here oh
god I hope I can you see me I hope I
landed near you I'm pretty far oh I see
you over okay I'm kind friend I'll just
wait here this is like it's gotta be
like a really important scene from some
movie look tell me you can see me Oh No
you're a yes sir there's these all three
of these emotes here I'm gonna try one
here
oh yeah give me give me give me yeah if
you had a 1 3 & 3 there on the condom
pad hi oh I'm running out of oxygen
where's my running out of oxygen emoji
this is like a debug thanks a few hit
zero just go back oh yay yes only to
implement the ability to use those but
that's awesome now like to have that
feeling of losing someone and finding
them again in space is like really
powerful I think that's what made Kerbal
like such a wonderful experience was
like the idea that you could get someone
to space but you couldn't bring them
home that was like one of the hard like
most heartbreaking things that happen to
me was like putting a little dude on the
moon and then being like he's gonna I
can't can't get him back yeah I being
able to leave this planet and getting
getting that ability but then trying to
come back to find you is really cool so
these are really wonderful and organic
experiences that you can only get from
games like those yeah I think once we
learn a lot of the bugs through it
through our early access and continuing
a lot of these will get those smoother
yeah there's still a lot of work to be
done but we're really seeing some
serious ground being gained here like so
thank you so much for showing me this
and like when can people start to pick
this up and what what platforms they
find this on like what what is this
available on we will be out in December
first steam early access and also on the
Xbox one game preview program and also
Windows 10 awesome and when can people
expect to find that hopefully around
late this year next year December be
before Christmas before Christmas what a
holiday treat well I don't know about
you guys but if you're down for some
serious space exploration with buddies
and this is up to how many people can
you play with it's just two of us but
there's more right up to four four
buddies can play in this world together
digging up resources wait here wait and
I just want to do one more thing oh yeah
can I go into this hole and dig a hole
and find you yeah I'll see if I can find
here oh they are yeah found you again
thank you guys so much for watching and
you guys can find out more about this
game as you find it online and mostly on
gamespot.com
so i'll see you guys again next time
yeah a bunch